-Our next guest is
a talented writer and comedian
whose critically acclaimed
one-woman show
"Get on Your Knees"
is running at the
Cherry Lane Theatre now.
Please welcome back to the show,
one of our favorites,
Jacqueline Novak.
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
-Welcome back!
I'm so happy we get to have yo
with a regular chair
and everything.
-My chair.
Sorry, I called it my chair.
-Well, I think that the people
who have seen you here befor
do believe
that it's fair for you
to call ownership of a chair
-Thank you.
-that you have
graced us with before.
I want to open with some
positivity, which is your show
-Thank you.
-has been extended
to July 31st.
-Yes. And, actually,
this is the formal announcement.
I brought it here.
-You did?!
-Yes.
-We're breaking news?
-We're breaking news.
It should be live
right now online
at getonyourkneesshow.com.
That is the title of the show,
as you're familiar.
-We've talked about, in a way,
both the joy and difficult
of discussing
the show here
on network television.
This is a philosophical
rumination
-Beautiful, Seth.
-about oral sex.
-Yes. And, specifically,
you know,
the kind related to the...
cylindrical object...
-Yes.
-...the...phallic sort...
-I think that's a good way
of saying it.
-...you know, versus the other
That's
-Right.
-been entirely left.
I shouldn't say other.
I'm really just splitting
these binaries.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, God, it's good to be here
I got to say.
-Let me ask a question.
-Yes.
-Or let me make,
instead of asking the question
a statement.
-Yes, please.
-I feel as though, when I
reached the university level
there were a lot of books
where people said,
"Oh, if you really read
James Joyce, you know,
oh, you know, they're actually
talking about, oh, sex
in a way that's, you know,
for the heady amongst us."
-Yes, yes.
Thank you.
-I feel like that's what
you're doing every night,
in a way that's a lot funnie
than James Joyce.
-Okay, thank you. I'll take it
-Yeah.
You're a modern Joyce.
-Oh, my.
-Plus laughs.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me just sit and soak
that in for a minute.
I come here to be
complimented primarily.
-Well, I hope you're
enjoying it, so far.
-I'm doing my usual lean,
my aggressive lean-in,
which, you know,
might be a bit --
-I don't know what to do anymore
because, see, I used to feel
like there was also
the pull of the audience,
so I was leaning both ways
and, now, I feel as though
you're my North Star.
-I am your North Star, actually.
Now, this is going
to be good for us.
I have so many things to say
I could barely --
I don't even know what to do
I'm like I'm excited.
I actually think there is
something to our audience
truly being
the audience at home.
-Yeah.
-Because you know how I feel
about television being
important, right?
And being on the small screen,
that sort of thing, being tiny
in their living room.
And so it's actually nice
to really have it be
about you people, you know
[ Laughter ]
I just wanted
to get all the cameras,
just in case I happen
to get it wrong, you know.
-The good news is they're a full
30 seconds
behind where you point.
[ Laughter ]
-That's hysterical.
-And no matter how much you tr
-That has to be true.
-to telegraph it, you're -
-I know. I know.
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
Shouldn't the light?
Anyway, I'm just learning
the tricks of the trade.
-I want to ask about this.
-Please.
-Do you have live audience
-I do.
-back, wearing masks?
-Wearing masks, fully masked
-I hope I don't get in trouble
with what I'm saying,
but your show is, again,
it's about oral sex
and I have done just a littl
bit of live performance
since things opened up again
-Yeah.
-I found audiences
to be at the ready.
-Oh, very.
-They're very happy to be out.
I don't want to tie it too close
to the theme of your show,
but it does feel as though
there is a bit of a releas
for people to be amongst one
another, laughing again.
-Yes. No, I think
it's great for me.
They seem very happy
to be there,
which is a good baseline
for starting a show.
And then, I don't mind
the masks, really,
I have to say.
-You don't?
-I might even institute a policy
of keeping them
for the rest
of my performing life.
I mean, I don't know.
What it does for me is
it takes some
of the pressure
off of their expressions
and I think maybe some
of the pressure they feel to
you know, make me feel saf
the whole time.
-I think you're right.
-They can just relax.
-I hadn't thought of that.
-They can just stare. They can
give me kind of nothing,
but still be enjoying it,
you know?
Like I saw one guy
who I thought --
Like I sort of clock, you know
I try to keep it going,
stay in the moment, of course,
stay present.
[ Indistinct ] want to go,
"Alright, I'm not sure
they're really enjoying it
Alright, I'll check back i
in a little while.
Have I won them over yet?
No," you know, and then,
I started to go, "Alright,
well, maybe there's just
a lot happening down here
that I'm not seeing,"
and I was alright with that.
-Well, that's so good
for me to hear
because I,
having seen you onstage,
I find you to be an incredibly
confident performer
who gives off the air
of not particularly caring
where the audience is at,
at any given moment.
But it's nice to hear
and I think
all performers need
to hear that.
You are also sort of...
-Full of terror.
-...yeah, clocking
the audience constantly?
-Yes. Well, I had a proble
in the past,
in previous runs,
where I'd get it in my hea
that someone either --
This is one example.
This one happened one night.
Someone either
looked a lot like Larry David.
Did I tell you?
Have I told you this?
-[ Laughing ] No.
-Looked a lot like Larry David
or could, perchance,
be Larry David.
Then I spent the entire show
thinking of every bit I did,
going,
"Would Larry David think
this was funny?"
And going like, "I think Larry
would find this funny."
I've had it
a couple other times,
like where I think someone's
in there and,
on the off chance they are
I feel myself catering.
No, but I am always full
of terror
-Yeah.
-and it's like there's
that one story
of Laurence Olivier or whatever,
that like he threw up
before every performance,
you know, 'til the end,
and that's that thing
where I'm comforted by that.
-Oh, it's so helpful to hear
people tell you the truth
about their own terror.
-Yes.
-Last time you were here
in person,
you were about to go on tour
How far into your tour
did you get
before COVID?
-A single date.
-One show?
-Yeah, one show.
And I was so prepared.
I was carving --
You know the big,
hard-shell suitcases?
I had these old ones
and I was ripping out the nylo
and putting Velcro up
and creating this entire
sort of like touring...
-Oh, wow.
-...you know, like setup
where I could grab all my
chargers and all my batterie
and just like so much tech
and I was like ready.
And then, obviously,
we were at home for a year
Which is great, too.
I was honestly really prou
that I had dates on the book
to cancel.
-Yeah, you're right.
-You know what I mean?
Like I was like, "Look at me
[ Laughter ]
Look at me.
I'm a real operator."
I was like, "Sorry, everyone
My, um, my shows were,
of course, canceled."
I was like so proud
and then, it took me
like a couple of weeks
to be like,
"Oh, it's kind of a bummer
that I'm not
getting to do these shows
right now."
-Again, this was a show
you did a lot.
-Yeah.
-I mean, like everyone
who is performing,
you had to take a long break
without doing it
in front of an audience.
Did it come back easy to you
It's a very --
-Dense.
-It's a very dense show.
-Yeah, yeah. It's dense.
There's a lot.
I mean, the good thing is,
if you skip something in it,
it kind of doesn't matter
because I go into everything
in such detail
that no one thinks something
didn't sound like
there was enough detail.
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
-I'm usually lingering too lon
on a given idea. [ Laughs
But, no, I'm actually
aggressively building
memory palaces.
This is one of these technique
that I get into in my --
-Wow!
You know,
where you lay things out
along the journey
of your hometown.
Oh, I drive down the stree
and then there's the first joke,
sitting on, you know --
-Have you always done that
-I'm always like looking
for a new strategy.
So it'll be like the night
before opening night
and I'm reading
the memory palace book
-[ Laughs ]
-like it's going to help me now.
And then, I got some rings -
clearly none --
but I got some rings
that we're going to be
visual cues.
I was going to have
the entire set list,
like fifty rings on my hands
and just be like,
"Oh, people just think
like this is my new style.
-You're a ring guy now.
[ Laughs ]
-I'm a ring guy now.
A couple earrings. I just like
"How can I cover my body?"
So, no. It never comes back.
Never comes back.
I don't know how I've done
the show so many times
and still feel like
I don't know it.
Even though it's "in me."
[ Raspily ] "It's in you,
you know. It's in you."
-Did you spend time --
I think this was
-Yeah.
-a burden that a lot
of performers put on themselve
over this time
that they had offstage.
Can you workshop
a show like yours,
when you don't have an audienc
to bounce it off?
-Well, so I filmed or tape
every show
that I did, you know,
every single night,
which is an old habit,
stand-up habit,
with the intention
that I would go through
every single performance,
line them all up
in "GarageBand," okay?
Literally.
Sorry,
Part of the Mac suite.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know how
to apologize for it,
despite its hideous chrome -
Anyway.
Its brushed chrome round edges
are like very embarrassing
Anyway. So I was going
to line them all up,
chop them all up,
and then line so it'd be lik
joke A gets to be next
to joke A, joke A, joke A,
and compare every single one
And then, I did that
for about two days,
then forgot I had started
that project,
and then, a year passed.
-[ Laughs ]
-So the answer is no.
But, artistically, I think
more energy went into merch.
I've realized that sort of
the evolution of the show
is really as a vehicle
for merchandise
and I'm fully working on that.
There's T-shirts. There's totes.
-Oh, that's exciting.
-Oh, for traveling.
-Because I've seen the show,
but nary a tote after.
-I know.
I'll get it tote over here
-Oh, that'd be great.
-I'll get a tote sent over
Yeah, I'm really just
a traveling salesman, now,
I think,
is kind of where it's at.
I am going to Boston,
by the way.
I should get that in.
Going to Boston in September
to do the show.
-Where are you going to do it?
-The Emerson Colonial.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah.
-That's really exciting.
-You're going to finally be able
to use your
Velcro'd-up suitcase.
-Exactly. Exactly.
-Yeah.
Well, I for one,
can't wait to see it again
-I can't wait to have you again.
-It is truly one of my favorit
stage performances
from the last five years.
And so lovely to have you back
Thank you for making time.
-Such a pleasure. Thank you.
-This is Jacqueline Novak.
Her show "Get on Your Knees"
is at the Cherry Lane Theatr
through July 31st.
We'll be right --
She's going to stand up no
and she's going to show yo
the full dress.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."